[Music]
benjamin is in boston massachusetts hi
benjamin welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
uh hi rachel how are you as well
yeah thanks for taking my call so i'm 26
years old i make about 72 000 a year
my fiance and i are set up to get
married in june we have our wedding all
planned and we're just kind of getting
stressed out here it's coming to be
pretty expensive
we both have student loans i have some
consumer debt that my my dad does she
might have
she makes about
50 000 so she's a doctor in residency
right now okay and how expensive is the
wedding
uh we're upwards of probably about forty
thousand dollars good god
yes sir i agree with you
benjamin's like i know well i mean for
somebody that makes this kind of money
that's a lot
well so we we live together obviously
we're we're engaged i make about 72 and
she makes about 50 so yeah it's it's a
big budget we are getting help from our
parents but how much help are you
getting from them
um
not they're certainly not covering the
whole wedding but i know how much help
are you getting from them
we don't we're kind of just like getting
help along the way they're kind of you
know okay here's what your problem is
your problem is not the amount
your problem is there's no end to it
because you've not said it you've not
set a wedding budget
no so yeah you guys need to sit down
tonight
and say okay
how much more that we've not paid for
already
is do we are we anticipating you need to
set manage this like a project
i don't mind somebody spending a hundred
thousand dollars on a wedding if they've
got the hundred thousand dollars and
they're wealthy people okay that's all
right but don't but don't just keep
spending and then wonder why you spent
too much you need to start the project
and say okay
this is how much we have for the dress
this is how much we have for the uh
reception this is how much we have for
the photographer and this is the total
and we're not going over that and we
both agree to that amount and benjamin
by doing this you guys are going to be
pulling numbers so say you've already
mapped out a photographer and you have
their price maybe you've already mapped
out a caterer and you have their price
like you're now that you guys actually
have things on paper and you're seeing
you may be like oh my gosh because i
know how those situations are and
especially if you don't have a budget
you're in a you know a meeting with the
caterer trying all this it's like yeah
let's add this and this because there's
no limit there's no boundary and now
that you actually have facts you guys
could go back and make different
decisions on different vendors and even
bring that forty thousand dollars down
some uh is a possibility as well i'm not
saying you guys
will have to do that depending on you
know what the budget ends up being but
having things on paper and seeing the
numbers makes you think differently than
just in the moment kind of going on a
whim
yeah absolutely and my other concern is
that we kind of disagree on how to
handle the money she wants to pay down
her loans
and i think we should be saving and
taking care of the wedding and i'm
trying to convince her to do how are you
going to pay for the wedding if you
don't save and pay for it
i guess that's a fair point but we just
we kind of disagree on what we should do
and i'm trying to convince her to do
financial peace and ramsay plus for
every dollar and i can't get her to
agree that it's worth it so i'm also
looking for advice on how i can convince
her of that all right we're going to
give that to you as a wedding present so
she has to go now because it's free and
it's my gift and she's going to hurt my
feelings if she doesn't know
so um because i you know i have a lot of
feelings and they're real i'm real thin
skinned and all and kind of tender and
and
soft and
benjamin tell her you're why tell her
your why
tell her your why of why you want this
smell to say hold on i'll still pick up
we'll get you signed up for fpu dude and
yeah you guys need to pay cash for the
wedding before you pay down your loans
you're right